[Music]
organic chemists make molecules very
complicated molecules by chopping up a
big molecule into small molecules and
get reverse engineering and as a chemist
one of the things I wanted to ask my
research group a couple of years ago is
could we make a really cool Universal
chemistry set
in essence could we app chemistry now
what would this mean and how would we do
it well to start to do this we took a 3d
printer and we started to print our
beakers and our test tubes on one side
and then print the molecule at the same
time on the other side and combine them
together and what we call reaction wear
and so by printing the vessel and doing
the chemistry at the same time we may
start to access this universal toolkit
of chemistry now what could this mean
well if we can bed biological and
chemical networks like a search engine
so if you have a cell that's ill you
need to cure or bacteria if you want to
kill if you have this embedded in your
device at the same time and you do the
chemistry you may be able to make drugs
in a new way so how are we doing this in
the lab will it require software it
requires hardware and it requires
chemical inks and so the really cool bit
is the idea is we want to have a
universal set of inks that we put out
with the printer and you download the
blueprint the organic chemistry for that
molecule and you make it in the device
and so you can make your molecule in the
printer using this software so what
could this mean well ultimately it could
mean that you could print your own
medicine and this is what we're doing in
the lab at the moment but to take baby
steps to get there first of all we want
to look at drug design and production or
drug discovery and manufacturing because
if we can manufacture it after we
discovered it we get deploy it anywhere
you don't need to go to the chemist
anymore we can print drugs at point of
need we can download new Diagnostics say
an
superbug is emerged you put it in your
search engine and you create the drug to
treat the threat so this allows you
on-the-fly
molecular assembly but perhaps for me
the Corbett going into the future is
this idea of taking your own stem cells
with your genes and your environment and
you print your own personal medicine and
if that doesn't seem fanciful enough
where do you think we're going to go
well you're going to have your own
personal matter fabricator beam me up
Scotty
[Applause]
[Music]